hey youtubers is Charlie so they just
released a bunch of new details about
arrow season 3 black Canary's back
there's gonna be a big time jump in that
first episode and all you olicity
shippers are gonna be really really
happy so this will be a breakdown of all
that stuff but hello any new people if
you're just finding me for the first
time I do weekly arrow videos and a lot
of DC stuff be sure to subscribe to get
everything
I'm even doing a special Comic Con
giveaway that I'll explain after all
this season 3 craziness so right off the
bat let's talk about where season 3 is
starting off on the timeline it's not
gonna pick up right after they stuck
Slade in the Argos prison at the end of
season 2 it's gonna jump forward several
months the producers didn't really give
an exact number but it's gonna be like
more than six enough time has passed
that Oliver's basically in chill mode as
the arrow and the rest of the team is
enjoying time out from the storm
that was Manu Bennett era in the flesh
has this thing where they kind of follow
a real-life time frame so for like every
month that it's been on hiatus team
arrow will be like on vacation so
Stephen Amell Emily BETT Colton David
all go on vacation
so does team arrow it's what they're
doing during this break period that was
making everyone go crazy earlier this
week in the official synopsis for
episode 1 which is titled to calm Oliver
totally asks Felicity out on a date you
know and all of a sudden the olicity
phantom cries out in triumph there's a
big asterisk attached to that but still
it's funny to think that the show is
actually going there it just proves that
a massive tumblr campaign can work so
high-five to all you elicit Egypt out
there you made this happen that first
episode takes a bit of a left turn with
they're supposed at romance but the rest
of the season is gonna address their
relationship the words used to describe
the situation where Oliver will explore
his feelings for felicity he'll actually
try to process whether he has real
feelings or if it's something else and
he'll make Felicity aware of that the
interesting thing on the other side of
that is what is Felicity gonna do once
she learns his intentions the moment
they shared on the beach was totally
real if you saw the way they were
looking at each other that wasn't a
trick or anything there was a lot of
sexual tension way more than normal and
now that Slade isn't trying to chop
their heads off they can deal with it
first we get our episode 1 olicity date
so let me explain the giant asterisk
that goes along with that in case you
didn't see recently Stephen Amell and
Marc Guggenheim were tweeting pictures
of this set when they were filming the
first episode there's like a whole lot
going on around these first couple of
episodes so some of it I'm just
push off to a separate bonus video but
they're basically at a boxing fight like
a boxing ring that's probably where
Oliver takes Felicity on their super
date the funny thing about that is is I
really see Oliver being a huge boxing
fan of course he'd be but I don't know
that Felicity would be a huge sports fan
it's a thing where you get someone else
a gift that's for them but you didn't
take the time to think if it's something
they would really be into that sounds
like something Oliver would totally do
just derp out the boxing ring actually
does sound like a pretty big scene they
actually posted a picture with a bunch
of blowup dolls sitting in the
background serving as extras you have
the big thing about this images is it
could be a big Easter Egg for the Ted
grant Wildcat he hasn't been announced
for this season but in the comics that
character was a big part of the Justice
Society and he was a boxer before
becoming a superhero so I'll totally do
a bonus video for him at some point too
because Geoff Johns is a big Justice
Society person he wrote it for a while
in that episode one description it
basically tees up a new villain barging
into Starling city and messing up their
date it doesn't sound like count vertigo
since he's supposed to be a drug dealer
and the villain is described as being
the second villain meaning I think he's
gonna be more like the brother blood
character a medium bad ball Peter
Stormare who's a pretty big actor will
be the big villain so supposedly this
mercenary is gonna be targeting people
associated with a certain company I'm
assuming it's gonna be the new company
formed when the atom character you know
Brandon Ross character comes in and buys
out Queen industries that doesn't mean
that he's necessarily targeting Oliver
but it's possible that count vertigo
hired that mercenary to keep team arrow
busy while he peddles his wares he's
basically gonna be selling that vertigo
drug or his version of it so the next
big season 3 WTF is Black Canary is
coming back in that first episode I know
what's going on at the end of season 2
she got on the boat to return with Nyssa
and the league to Nanda Parbat the
explanation is is that it's that
mercenary killer the new villain that
brings her back he or she is supposed to
be wanted for killings in several
countries so either Sara's been tracking
them or she comes back to intercept
Caity Lotz has not been listed as a cast
regular like all the new people and John
Barrowman
so what does that mean for the Black
Canary character she'll probably just be
in a few episodes unless she's just in
that first one I don't think they're
gonna be making Laurel put on black
leather any time soon so keeping Sara
around longer is just another way to
stall that transformation I was actually
really big fan of caity lotz in season 2
she didn't get a lot of scenes I feel
like she needed some more screen time
but I'm interested to see if her arrival
complicates the Oliver Felicity dynamic
a little bit it's like the writers want
there to be people from all sides making
it impossible for Oliver and Felicity to
address what's going on between him on
Felicity side of things the brain and
Ralph Adam character is gonna be one of
those big new ships he's gonna be like a
science version of Oliver you know with
the muscle so I'm expecting him and
Felicity to have a lot of chemistry it's
all part of the process of tearing team
arrow apart during the season then
putting it back together at the end like
right now they're writing hi and they're
all super close so in the new story
season 3 they'll just get slapped around
a whole lot like last year and then by
the end they'll be made whole again and
stronger for the experience I know that
sounds like an oversimplification but
that's essentially what the hero's
journey is you know you tear him down
then you build him back up
but what's going on with the other
characters because there's actually
several big ones that we haven't talked
about yet a lot of you guys asked me
about detective Lance at the end of last
season he was basically dying in the
street but because of that time jump I
mentioned in the first episode he's
gonna be fully recovered and he's a
captain now so he and Oliver are gonna
have much more of a Batman Corden
relationship it's just that now Quentin
is gonna have the power to help him like
he'll have the resources by the time
that first episode picks up the city
will have acknowledged the arrow as a
hero so he's not a vigilante that
they're hunting anymore so moving on to
Roy's character he's gonna be settling
into his role as Arsenal that's just
what they're turning him into on the
show the version of the character he's
also still gonna be pining away for Thea
I'm sure he's been deep powered but
Oliver never had powers so Oliver just
gonna be Sam and laddering his ass into
shape next to him every day I'm also
really interested to see how the
addition of Brandon rouse character to
team arrow effects Roy in Oliver's
relationship I actually think it's gonna
bring him closer together
Roy's personality is a lot closer to
Oliver's than Ray Palmer's Roy is not a
science bro so whenever the Addams
personality starts to dominate team
arrow I think that Roy's gonna gravitate
even closer to Oliver they're
introducing his character Brandon rouse
character in the first couple of
episodes but think of it as like a
modified Isabel rochev arc Ray Palmer
his real-life persona is taking over
Queen industries Palmer's company is
buying them out so he's Oliver the new
boss I'm sure you're all imagining the
hilarious boardrooms
scenes where he starts shushing Oliver
in front of felicity they haven't
revealed when Palmer is going to become
the atom or if they'll already have the
gear whenever the show starts I feel
like seeing him develop the persona
would be way too much fun to waste so I
really hope we get to see that
progression on-screen at least by the
mid-season finale so on the flip side
let's not forget about Malcolm Merlyn
and Thea he's gonna be a cast regular
John Barrowman is that means he's gonna
be in most of the episodes but it's
unclear what his story arc is gonna be
whether he's gonna try and rebuild his
empire or just seek revenge on everyone
last year Stephen Amell did this Q&A
where he said something really
interesting
he said that Oliver and Malcolm have a
lot of unfinished business I think that
after dark he's gonna be taking jabs at
Oliver and during the day he's gonna be
taking on Ray Palmer and the new Queen
industries company remember Merlyn lost
his company too so just like Oliver he
might be trying to get it back you can
let me know if you agree but I feel like
we got cheated out of a Merlyn Oliver
team-up in the season 2 finale so I'm
really hoping we get to see that
sometime during season 3
I really hope John Barrowman becomes the
Loki of the series jumping back and
forth between helping and hurting team
arrow so I think I'm gonna wait to talk
about the rest of the characters till
after the comic-con panel just because
we'll learn a lot of new information
during that and yes to everyone asking I
will be there and I will record it I'll
be uploading parts of it be sure to
subscribe to get everything it's gonna
be a lot of fun during the week at Comic
Con I'm gonna be posting a whole bunch
of the panel's I'll have a link in the
description so you can vote on which
ones you want the most it'll just help
me prioritize which stuff I post first
they will be screening footage from
arrow season 3 probably the first couple
of episodes I won't be able to upload it
just because of legal issues but if they
do post it to the web that I'll let you
guys know here's what's going on with my
arrow giveaway - starting right now you
can enter to win a copy of the arrow
season 2 blu-ray or DVD your choice it's
not on sale till September so you get a
pre-order basically all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video so I'll leave the
giveaway open til the week after Comic
Con so you have plenty of time to enter
but later tonight I'm working on a flash
bonus video I'm gonna be explaining all
the different versions of the
reverse-flash so you can click here to
get that a lot of the invitations as
soon as I post it and you can click here
to learn all about Brandon rouse new
Atom character thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tonight
high fives
you